6 26 on your monday morning a shout out
to the nevada highway patrol you know
nhp troopers are out there
for all of us 24 7 365 and that includes
taking
bad drivers off the freeways over the
long thanksgiving weekend we'll probably
never know the potential disasters they
averted so
thank you nhp got a couple of tweets i
wanted to show you first
how about speeds like this 128 miles per
hour
the tweet continues they're completely
unacceptable it's complete disregard for
your own safety and everyone else's who
shares the road with you
is going to be an expensive lesson for
this driver
then how about this one hashtag one less
gun or actually
two less guns troopers on a graveyard
shift arrested a convicted felon
in possession of two loaded firearms
while on a traffic stop
will stupid drivers ever figure it out
well there aren't enough troopers to
capture
all of them but thank goodness these two
were taken into custody
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there's something
driving you crazy email me
traffic eight at eight news now dot com
john very busy on